for 10 years you're doing the shittiest
jobs
in l.a what was the list of jobs that
you did in la that
that just to make a living well i do
want to clarify one because
people always ask me if i worked at a
hot dog cart
yes i've heard that it's very different
i worked at a hot dog
restaurant oh well
different well no it was actually this
little hot
whenever i describe it it sounds crazy
i've never heard it it was
what was it it was in beverly hills and
it was a like a gourmet
hot dog place and actually one of the
first celebrities that i ever met was
john lovitz and he came in there
i made him a hot dog is that why in the
new movie you make hot dog soup i like
the salt i like the hat dad
maybe that's a subconscious that's what
you did you wrote it
yeah when lovitz walks in and uh he's a
fan of your hot dogs does he hit on you
because you know
john was probably saying he didn't no
but i remember
he's not even gonna know this story he
he came in and i remember he
he came in and he had just bought like a
new camera or something
and he was just kind of like figuring it
out and we were like talked about it and
then
but i was freaking out because i
when i first got to la like i you know i
remember the very first celebrity i saw
was joey butterfucko and a cvs
um and john lovitz was was soon after
and i was
so excited by the way how many hot dogs
did lovitz eat
oh my god what is he taking on his hot
dog
oh my god this is like 20 i have no idea
i don't know